what is going on there oh God I always
do this I gotta do a koi style citizens
of the reject Nation we are going to
continue the Kung Fu Panda Trilogy with
Kung Fu Panda 3 bringing it full circle
joined by the man who just landed in
from Rome koi genre show them the back
of your shirt it is appropriate look at
that doesn't he look like a character
look at that right there from the Kung
Fu Panda Universe shirts from Ireland
but I flew near and straight blast is
the style of martial art that I feel
like Kung Fu Panda depreciate that is
true I appreciate your words and wisdom
bringing back your coin ladies and
Gentlemen please leave a like on this
video that would mean the world I want
to thank you all who have been on this
journey with us this has been a pleasant
surprise for both koi and I really been
having a lot of fun speaking of fun I
want to thank everyone because we sold a
crap ton of shirts for space baby shirt
I showed this for the first time on Kung
Fu Panda 2. it's almost our number one
selling shirt at Zero edition so guys if
you want to get yourself a space baby
shirt go to shopzeroedition.com it's one
of the best ways to support the channel
and also one of the best ways to support
the channel is one of the best ways you
get an awesome experience at Kung Fu
Panda 3 by joining our patreon page
become a super sexy reject today once
again massive gratitude to all who have
joined because we've been doing so many
movie reactions we've been doing so many
movie reactions that a lot of you have
been joining us over there I could hear
the music for the intro in my head as
I'm doing this one can do it I I can't
actually hear right now it's just funny
that my mind just gotta just left my
body for a second but yeah guys I cover
so many things exclusively over their
reaction highlights and watch songs
included I've spoken enough let's go
hey
what
it's so calmly hi old friend
Master Oogway it's a different kind of
opening well now I'm ready for a rematch
took you long enough
I like this music gorgeous
you've grown stronger
[Music]
oh Neato I have taken the chi of every
Master here and soon I will have your
power too when will you realize the more
you take the less you have theme
cool
wow with your chi I will finally be able
to return to the mortal world
will be there to stop me
oh no I have set another on that path
he dies again what a turtle life then I
will find him
and take his G2 so in this world the chi
is like their life force is a soul too
yeah yeah their whole experience what a
chill Zen Turtle even his Chi Justice is
about to be served
[Music]
where are they going dinner
noodles
we'll have two Justice platters please
yes served never underestimate the power
of a dramatic entrance I've heard about
some Masters who can win a fight just by
throwing open a door
[Music]
before the battle of the Fist comes the
battle of the Mind hence
the dramatic entrance
that is a dramatic entrance my final
class because from now on your training
will be in the hands of the Dragon
Warrior oh whoa
me Teach I mean why not tiger She's
always telling
to do be quiet po you see what I mean
let me show you another move
the dramatic exit what's that
[Laughter]
he's gone guys it's cool we await your
instruction master
oh no fire fire stop what are you
teaching them did you at least learn a
little something yes
that you can't teach and Tigress is
flammable turns out what were you hoping
to teach them from that what could have
occurred
back to square one PO
he said you're a loser
that's a great cut Tigers told me yeah
well did she also tell you that it'll
never happen again because I'm done
teaching or being humiliated both I
don't know why you ever thought I could
teach that class you learn a lot from
humiliation winner learn Panda if you
only do what you can do you will never
be more than you are
word
oh we can heal
life force restore the chi already water
bended now he's life force bending what
was
what was that was G mastering G requires
Mastery of self Oogway sat alone on a
cave for 30 years oh how boring
you're never gonna be like you I'm
trying to turn you into you study
practice teach is that a discipline yeah
[Music]
I love the music that you compose for
this guy yeah it's a little zestier
general Kai Supreme warlord of all China
Jade
slee is the Beast of Vengeance JK
Simmons yeah I just heard it
bring them to me oh my God he can
control the Masters like Shazam with the
sins well Shifu says I don't know what
it means to be the Dragon Warrior now I
have to be a teacher Kung Fu that's a
promotion I take the caption
oh Mrs Chow always wins that it's good
[Laughter]
the cutaways are solid
[Music]
oh my God his dad is this how he meet
his dad or someone related him who are
you sir
it's Brian Cranston yeah last time it
was Jack Black though remember he voiced
himself yeah
very sorry thank you
I hope you find yourself
put it together I hope you find you a
father
the first Panda they've seen
I can't believe you're alive
oh no oh see little Lotus was the name
you were given at Birth oh Dad
come say hi to
um I don't know what I'm supposed to
call you I'm pretty sure he said his
name is Lee
that was great
if we're taking a picture together
huh
I taught Poe was the only Panda left
there's a whole bunch of us where a
secret
a secret panda
you're flying rhinos battle armor I
wonder if I could fit in that get out of
my head Dad I've wondered the same thing
if I could fit in if you could know if I
could fix it
what this does I should pull it
[Music]
oh my God it's a Mecca suit
go along son
wow I wasn't ready coming back at you
guys
ouch you guys are gonna destroy this
whole King the whole Temple
oh
Joe oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
dad say hi to my friends that's cute
that they were like monkey brain they're
willing to ignore all the destruction
yeah yeah Dad's here that's matters the
Valley's under attack
under attack this is perfect now you can
see what being the dragon Warrior's all
about how's it going to catch up there
to the fight in time and then the armor
enemies of Justice
I think what are you kidding me
what's the deal with the green guys
some kind of Jade zombies the master
Badger twins with their crushing double
gong technique that guy is
porcupine arrows
I blinked let's get another one
watch out
to do
power up
Ah that's cool gotcha
teamwork and food
is he talking about which one they're
all talking we should try that too maybe
back at them okay but we got a plan
we're gonna say first otherwise it won't
be scary it'll just be stupid
it's me talking through that time
was that
guy
Kai
not never
never
I like that the other two are legends
that he's like trying to be important to
know what else do I do who he is long
ago I had a brother we had a brother in
arms in arms sorry he says I was an
ambitious young Warrior leading a great
Army now here we go finally the
animation opening animation one day we
were ambushed I was badly wounded my
friend carried me for days oh he was
caring until we came to a secret village
high in the mountains an ancient place
of healing pandas oh healing who used
the power of chi to heal me oh my God he
was destined oh it's within Poe the yin
yang of black and white Bears I wanted
the power all to himself he saw that
what could be given could also be taken
is that a thing like pandas are balanced
because they're black and white is that
a thing we'll look it up all right I
banished Kai to the spirit realm he can
only be stopped by a true master of chi
damn green like you me I can barely make
a flower bloom I need at least 30. does
he know how to do that
but he probably hasn't suppressed it due
to the trauma from being ambushed and
he's gonna find himself on the same
Journey oh there it is never mind okay
we were waiting
immediately wrong
I got you I'm dead it's not that story
you can't take power away from me this
guy can only be stopped by Master of chi
I'm a panda I'll pack your lunch for the
road this dad has just been getting
neglected every move every film left
behind every film you are going to find
out where Kai is follow the trail of
those Jake creatures but do not engage
and take mantis what oh man is it
because I yes hahaha
this sounds weird to say because it's an
animated franchise for families way
younger feels the most kid-friendly all
the jokes are like for kids and all of
it is very like telegraphed yeah but
it's still fun still fun it's still fun
and beautiful way young but it does feel
like more younger yeah I've been
thinking that you don't need to ask me
twice
dad
yes Dad yes
I do think Brian Cranston is perfect
casting for the tattoo paternal snarky
here
my son hates stairs so
go home
Amanda's we don't do stairs I've waited
my whole life to hear those words
oh it is not illustrious what's going on
here Doom and Gloom now you can whoa
whoa whoa po oh there it is there it is
just Misty Shangri-La Panda Shangri po
pangrila pangrila
oh
[Music]
maybe try Rolling On Your Side not good
at panding
New Chopsticks they're for picking up
dumplings
[Music]
[Laughter]
its own hand
it's gonna fall in love what about
Tigress why does she keep staring at me
like that try to keep up
Amy Schumer I was wondering if that's
her because I was getting Rebel Wilson
Amy Schumer vibe
yeah but you just figure out the chi
you know I mean saving the world
maybe a priority but it has to know
himself
imbecile you're seriously afraid even
Master chickens going in there and he's
a chicken
they're like Donkey Kong characters
hahaha
I'm going in mantis we have orders we
need our help come on taking her cheek
s
oh crap we lost Rogan
nice
strong just like your
the bug Matt
one inch flick got skadooshed I'm ready
for my first day of panda training the
panda sleep till past noon so lesson
number one is go back to bed of course
nobody said this was gonna be easy
I feel like Bryan cranston's doing a
John Goodman impression oh yeah I could
call lunchtime
[Music]
oh my God
you're gonna need to learn to roll for
the final fight it's gonna be part of it
[Music]
oh what are you doing there
oh
frustrating feeling relaxed totally just
let yourself fall into it got it
[Music]
subtle po very subtle
oh an entanglement
[Applause]
so you just had a great time it's just
living life that's Panda life just
happiness the opposite of his training
in the first movie is to learn to relax
and sleep in to find himself where's mom
or she died
she died in the actual thing that we
thought he died in it yeah when do you
think I'll be ready ready you know to
learn how to master Chi soon real soon
come on I want to show you something
else I just wanted to spend time with us
he manipulated him your mama couldn't
hold you still you nearly ate the paper
she was the love of my life
and then along you came my little Lotus
low not Lee and low
[Music]
okay so she was just part of the
genocide you don't have to worry about
losing me ever again
but
a dragon warrior you gotta go fight
there bro great mantis still nothing oh
wait it's them
oh
hi
this plot feels very anime I like it a
lot of what he can do this might have
the best score I will destroy it
anything he has created
cool always cool the fights are still
great though man yeah
who knocked some Chi out of them
will not let you destroy your grace
memory
oh
sorry sorry
actually feels like Jackie Chan gotta do
some Voice works for me he actually
showed up today
great shot
oh no it's exactly our fight with Seth
Rogen and Jackie Chan what happened to
[Music]
my God
man I will show you the true power of
great shot though
oh with his own statue guys we all have
to move to the secret village now
it's the only place we can live
[Music]
damn that's a beautiful destruction
always be someone to
who the panda he will meet the same fate
no you can't take on all the pandas it's
funny you could kind of interchange JK
Simmons and Brian Cranston oh yeah yeah
I wonder how often they go up against
each other for Gravelly dad especially
on voice voice over work they could do
either roll yeah I wonder if after life
Chi is different than in life Chi it's
probably more peaceful maybe unless you
got some showing up trying to
take it away from him he's got that
necklace I wonder if it's a different
spot because all the all the in-life
cheese seems to be around the waist he's
taken every master in China including
Shifu and the others it's it's all gone
po everything everyone everyone everyone
the bunnies the pigs all been
slaughtered it's a good thing daddy
tagged along
everyone else is murdered I don't have
more time I need to learn it now sorry
you're not ready I am totally at one
with my panda Parks now why won't you
cause I don't know it
son of a
Heisenberg done messed up your dead wife
would be a shame
oh I am not going to lose you again
[Music]
not how it works you just did
yeah don't lie to you kid
whoa this just got really dramatic
wow everyone's dead I like it
don't enjoy being right about everything
[Laughter]
amazing I can't hear it
[Music]
oh he may be a monster but he's still
your father
he's so much funnier yeah he's great and
he's always been supportive like a good
dad yep
[Music]
third act montage
heard you still pull from me but I
realize having you impose life doesn't
mean less for me
it means more for Paul
um
I lied to him I lied to him for 20 years
sometimes we do the wrong things for the
right reasons that's what I say every
time you get caught he's gotta you know
he's gotta try to do it for the right
reason navigate that that's why I stole
from you
he still has to save the world
he needs both his dad oh family Jesse
[Music]
really should be working on the Tai Chi
the chi element there we go there we go
come on Tigress I've seen what he can do
but he hasn't seen what I can do the
whooshie finger hold
it's my best move I just have to get to
Kai grab his finger and then skadoosh
he can only be stopped by a master of
chi oh you sound just like Shifu with
the cheat cheat
[Laughter]
unless you had an army of your own
that's right a bunch of rolling Panda
all the pandas have to come together
all of us
all through this slump and exhaustion
from walking into that's all they got
you don't even know Kung Fu then you
will teach us I can't teach you Kung Fu
I could
oh it was good
we can learn Kung Fu we can be just like
you yes we can no
that's what Shifu meant I don't have to
turn you into me I have to turn you into
you
yeah exactly get your chiability back
your real strength comes from being the
best you you can be so who are you what
do you love what makes you you
this is classic training a whole village
who's about to be attacked very classic
and I know the rolling's gonna come into
play hug that log like it's the last
time you're ever gonna hug it goodbye
forever
and a little more to the left this time
you can do it
I literally faded into this animation
it's so epic they're doing like Panda
stuff
it's like playing with its own Trope
yeah
[Music]
I love this backstory there is a lot I
love about it though I don't I can't
either yeah there's a lot I do
love about it it's really coming
together in the third act for me yeah
now try it with these
ah
ah this is clever embracing who you are
so pretty
oh they are ready
amazing
while the cookie Squadron will take
position here now on my signal the two
squadrons will
the important thing to remember is that
this is the spot where
if you only remember one thing it's
distracted zombies until I get close
enough to put a wooshy finger hold on
pie jumps
I wish I could have taught you this son
it's okay dad remember who you are
[Music]
that's what I call a dramatic entrance
hahaha
[Laughter]
he's like exposed so so good finally
thank you almost makes me want to spare
your life oh you want to spare me
you spare me that chat
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh cool you guys have all been
turned green
except for you mantis you were already
green
dumpling Squad
[Music]
spring roll Squad time for some takeout
nicely done
Danger
[Music]
oh my God an actual nunchuck fight yeah
it's like what Jackie Chan protects an
antique yeah
Master Shifu wait do you have to fight
the turtle
I can and so can I double dare defense
let's finish this
yeah
I didn't even see the roll coming
[Music]
gotta send you back to the spirit Realm
skadoosh
it only works on Mortals and I
am a spirit Warrior
no there's no bueno oh
save him with your Chi Papa remember the
chi Palmer save him everyone use your
Chi
if you really thought you could send me
back to this the spirit Realm
what are you thinking
he doesn't have to send him there he's
gotta make him mortal and then
but I can take you there what's that
oh
shh
didn't see that coming oh damn
[Music]
oh the greatest sacrifice
skadooshing yourself skeducing yourself
can have multiple meanings it really can
you brought me back don't play me I
tried to finish this in the regular
round
suck it in man
how
[Music]
no poop dad remembers your tree
we have to help him we can do this
just follow your heart you told us who
we were meant to be
a father
oh a friend
a dumpling kicker chick
y baby
family
oh
[Music]
oh that is beautiful
Epic
oh
yeah he's super saiyan Panda now
who are you
I've been asking the same question
I am Ray Skywalker the son of a goose
student
a teacher I'm all of them
that's awesome
oh it's full circle I am the Dragon
Warrior beautiful cool see the giant
dragon
you're ready to feel the Thunder this is
awesome wow
[Music]
oh
my heads up
[Music]
ouch
you want my cheese so bad
then take it
yes the power is mine implode him like
Neo and agent Smith yeah from the inside
breaks the code
[Music]
secret Village Ain't So secret yeah
you are extra shiny and are you I know
right it's like the best Cape ever when
I run with it then it looks really cool
[Laughter]
gotta lay off the Panda Buffet grown up
I hope you would when I sent the message
to your father
oh
I love the cherry blossom imagery and
all these I saw the future kung fu and
the pears
I saw the panda who could unite them
both
that is why I chose you Poe this is good
tethering to the first one yeah
my true successor I can't take that just
take it I have a bigger one
there's you who must decide whether to
stay or go I can go back who knows
I've never tried
so Zen
like The Legend of Korra
wait where did you get that
just dawned on me that it did teach the
village yeah
I think I mastered G oh
can you teach me oh now he's the teacher
oh they've combined forces Everybody Was
Kung Fu Fighting
[Music]
we are all Poe
so they do in Christian churches Palm
stuff
foreign
oh my God they've healed everything
super bloom
oh ultimate Chi
and while that really does feel like a
an ending yeah
like that does a beautiful resolution of
a trilogy
I I wonder what the fourth one would be
uh well the first one is about
discovering his inner warrior second one
was about believing in himself
third was about discovering himself
the next one is about discovering
another well the third one was about was
I mean all three are essentially his
journey of identifying himself but but
like different versions of himself right
yeah yeah and then this is where he
comes into his full self in his third
one it's like it's a great Arc
way off way off
blonde yeah that's true guest blondes
who do we know as like overweight
comedic actresses that voice definitely
sounded like yeah it's Ali ABC over yeah
I love that Jackie Chan got to play
because like it felt like a waste a lot
to not have him Jackie Chan he actually
got to do some stuff uh but I think it's
a great uh I I think regardless of where
this would
stand because I still there's still a
lot about it that I loved and like the
last half of this like definitely I
thought it really helped improve the
experience so much because I would still
put this as third out of the three same
but I still really I there's I I loved
like the last half a lot especially the
last like 20 30 minutes it's one of the
best recoveries I've ever seen yeah like
because in the first half I'm not gonna
lie two and a half maybe out of five
yeah last half
four I think it lands at a three and a
half yeah I thought it got a lot better
as it went it's like while that first
half had definitely had some moments
that were still like fun and enjoyable
it felt very young yeah it was it was an
interesting experience to have one it is
a family movie yet it it seemed the
especially the second one seemed to
mature a lot more and then to regress
and I'm wondering how much that was Fox
wanting to be more marketable because
DreamWorks I think of as more story
driven and having elements that the
story is first yeah and then like I
don't think of fox animation much I
think of Sony I think of universal
DreamWorks and I think a Disney with
Pixar so I'm wondering if they were like
we got to make it marketable and I also
wonder too what they because this came
out a few years apart from the second
one because I think the second one
actually wasn't a huge hit when it came
out and then it eventually garnered like
its audience that it needed to to warn
the third one if I'm not I could be
wrong about that but I'm pretty sure
someone did mention that to me okay so
there could be a trajectory there it's
crazy that it ended with a cliffhanger
and they were like maybe yeah but still
I I what I what I really respect about
this is that if the third one still
feels like a central viewing yeah with
its context because it is the complete
story it does feel like it completes the
entire story regardless it reminds me of
the future sure where the first two are
amazing and the third one the second
half is amazing it ties all together
no no it's great but you know what I
mean the first half of the third one is
not as strong as the first two to me
yeah yeah and then like it but it's all
one story yeah and I think having it be
like one complete story that's why I was
wondering like what would your fourth
one be I assume if he's become the
teacher and like that's the ultimate of
like teacher Master The Apprentice he
would have to pass along the the dragon
warrior-ness like maybe as a kid maybe
he like he he you know is the he's the
red panda roll oh my God I should have
said it out loud I thought the big Panda
was Wayne Knight I was thinking that you
was Pax Jolie Pitt little Brad Pitt
Angelina Jolie kid then they were doing
the whole thing about children I was
wondering if they actually got the kids
in there I love it yeah I was wondering
if those are the actual you should have
said I had two thoughts that I did not
expressed that I was going I wonder if
those are actually the kids and yeah it
was because you did so much casting
in the first one you were like maybe not
this time and then whenever I guess
something out loud I tended to be wrong
yeah and then now it's on records
Because the Internet yeah uh that was an
incredible second half and uh I was
really worried the first half because I
really wanted to love it and then I
found myself being like the beauty of
really good animation is it's all ages
and like all ages isn't the same as y a
like all ages is truly parents can watch
it with their kids and get different
experiences but the first half felt like
not all ages and then they found this
amazing shift when suddenly the jokes
got funnier for all ages the world felt
more like it trusted the audience like
that was a really special Trilogy like
this is one of the great trilogies I I
truly think that was by the end I get
why this is so beloved yeah it
recaptures that beauty and wonder
because yeah a lot of the humor it had
that effect that you might hear what a
lot of people say with like Marvel
movies where they wouldn't just let like
certain scenes just settle with like a
dramatic moment or a little bit of
tension there had to be like a joke you
could feel like that script note of like
get a joke in there all the time get a
joke and while the first two are also
really really funny movies
the it never felt like the jokes would
undercut a moment and I would actually
feel that in the first half of this film
and and with this villain too while I
love the animation style what they did
and the way they like Illustrated
everything with his I don't know what
the names of the weapons are but those
flies yeah those are great those are
amazing uh I thought it was really cool
and while he ought to have been the most
threatening villain because of the way
this movie was paced and how they would
flesh out the scenes with him he kind of
just felt generic which is weird because
you got JK Simmons you've got all these
like subplots with the other Warriors
you've got all the elements but it never
landed for me and it felt like they the
context could have lent itself to
something that did feel really like
Primal and personal especially with the
history of what he has he should have
felt like the biggest threat and yet it
didn't quite amount to that I didn't
really feel any sense of true threat
until until he was with Poe and the
skadoosh didn't work I was like oh okay
here we are but then lasted just like
yeah and then it's over because well I
love the music around him and while I
thought the animation around like the
fight scenes I still thought they did an
excellent job at I still think the
fights were incredible to look at the
animation was just as great and I love
Brian Cranston as the dad I think he was
like perfect casting yeah I love the
dad's element I really like that uh they
kept the love of cinematography and they
kept the love of fighting but they
enhanced like the textures like the fur
looked better and better the lighting
was obviously stunning I love the
Montage of learning to be pandas of
yourself in that incredibly like intense
visual but it's like eating I really
liked those comedic elements but it took
a while to get to the point where it
felt like the audience was trusted to
let it be that and I definitely think
the score was the best in this one but
the first half was a struggle but I do
think it's all worth it by the time it
lands like the the elements that we
talked about with the trilogy trusting
itself there should have been more of
he's becoming the master and he has to
fight all the other Masters he has to
find himself after thinking he's already
found himself his dad asked to you know
discover all these things and that's a
great juxtaposition with the villain but
it it definitely felt like they they
were you know hands off a little like
sugar coating it a little bit a little
bit but then it got there yeah and I
think the lesson learned about who we
identify as it was great because that is
what makes everyone unique is the
experience that we all have like that
everyone is unique due to the fact that
no individual can have the exact same
life experiences one-to-one ratio right
as you and so that's why I always say
unique starts with the letter U it's so
to find out who your unique self is that
is all through the experiences that you
uh accumulate over time and that forms
your identity and I love that by the end
of it all that's what that is what he is
embracing is his entire past and instead
of trying to conform to something he is
accepting of all so I thought that
lesson is actually beautiful I didn't
even see the arcs are usually pretty
telegraphed yeah this one was like I
didn't actually predict that's where he
would land and I thought that was a
really poignant way to go about with his
character Arc there that does encompass
the entire Trilogy as well like it not
only does it for this film but the
entire Trilogy I always say the best
Series have the 3x structure per film
and then there's also this incredible 3x
structure I usually since most people
follow me for Marvel reference the
Captain America Iron Man Thor those
three arcs and how they kind of like you
know mix with each other like selfless
to selfish with Captain American and
Iron Man and then Thor is beautifully
just like trying to figure out self but
all of those are individual movie arcs
and then there's this overarching Arc
I'm so impressed that this film is every
single Kung Fu Panda is him discovering
who he is and there's still more to
discover of who you are and then the
third one is like a nine act structure
because you've got the three acts in
each of the films and there's this
beautiful overarching self of all of who
you are yeah and I love that like you're
saying The Who I Am is individual to me
because whenever I talk about favorite
movies and things people get so angry at
the specificity but it's it's no one has
lived even a twin is going to be
different than a twin you lived
differently and I love that the movie
found a way to embrace that while
getting young two old people to just
accept who they are I think it's a
really important film it's an important
message too because I think people
struggle with their identity a lot yeah
it's kind of like an ongoing thing of
self-discovery so I think doing three
movies about self-discovery also
justifies its per its sequels it's the
same yeah I think I felt that every time
as opposed to just doing something
that's plot Centric because yeah even
though like it's part of the execution
of the first half wasn't 100 working for
me
the I didn't feel like this plot wasn't
necessary to tell like it felt like a
necessary story to it that's really
interesting even when I wasn't invested
as much as I felt I wanted to be I was
still happy to be here and I was still
like I'm glad they made this and I kept
thinking like there's a new audience for
this and that made me happy every time I
felt myself drift but I kept coming back
yeah and the way they did resolve the
whole thing with the dads I thought was
kind of a unique angle to have as well
and I love the way that came together I
thought Goose dad was the funniest he's
ever been oh he was excellent and I love
that Tigris is still mysterious but like
we get a little bit more for every time
I wish she my only note is I wanted a
little bit more her because of where we
left off in two yeah but I feel like her
backstory is a little dark for what they
were telling here and I'm hoping in four
we get some like Tigress like maybe
that's how we get a protege maybe
there's a little tigers maybe there's a
little Panda tiger baby you know what I
noticed is there's never been a romance
not a single one and I think that's
really cool how they did not they've
never leaned on that you saw dungeons
dragons right yeah I love the fact that
the relationship between this isn't a
spoiler it's just they established at
the very beginning yeah but uh the Chris
Pine and Michelle Rodriguez is platonic
and I love that they didn't make it uh
like 90s action movie plot yeah I
thought they were gonna have him fall in
love with uh
Kate Hudson I thought they were gonna
have a follow-up with uh her uh but that
is not the case at all I really really
enjoyed the second half I wonder if in
the next one they introduced western
civilization and then posed dad gets
shot oh and turned into soup and then oh
which dad I thought the goose
I also love that they didn't get rid of
the mom as a subplot but they also let
it be about the dads without it feeling
like the the generic jealousy was only
serving the actual narrative it didn't
become like so much that it underwrote
either character yeah because it could
have become that it could have been the
whole movie a lesser movie would have
been like the fighting dads yeah yeah
and I love when they suited up with the
thing they set up at the Rhino suit in
the beginning there were so many great
callbacks to not just the first film but
this film again like a 9x structure yeah
yeah I think I think there was some
potential that they could have
definitely uh leaned in on that could
have made more of an impact uh not just
with his main villain because JK Simmons
is great casting it's cool to have him
here because I mean I've seen all Legend
of Korra and there's a lot of elements
Legend of course the sequel to Avatar
got it and um so it's like the Avatar
religion horror world and uh JK Simmons
is one of the main characters in Legend
of Korra but he's like the nice Mentor
guy yeah he's a sweetheart so he could
have easily played the Brian Cranston
part yeah Brian krantzen easily could
have played the JK that's why I was like
listening it's kind of funny they could
have just switched them up if they
wanted to
um so it's cool seeing him here and
there were so much references like
especially with like the spirit world
and the animals that were really making
me uh look back on it and there was a
lot of like anime plot points but I did
think even the jaded it's like the way
they introduced things that it the
threat was never really felt and I think
that's part of what was missing here was
the villains in the first two whenever
you cut to them even Gary oldman's uh
Peak one was funny at times but
also very menacing and I think that
Menace intention when you were around
them was very much absent when you were
here with them and to go from villains
that became progressively more
interesting to something that felt like
uh we got to get the outline out of the
way of what their backstory is and just
kind of go by nowhere I was missing a
little subtext and even the jaded I
thought you know like every main bad guy
has their henchmen sure except for the
first guy with it but uh you know having
their henchmen and having the jaded Chi
Spirits these are Masters at your
disposal and I really thought that they
could would have made that even more
threatening and actually had some actual
Stakes when you're fighting them but it
always felt like no they got those guys
handled yeah it's just the main bowl
that you got to worry about and so I
thought that was a missed opportunity
and the other main missed opportunity
with character that I thought they
really could have done and maybe there's
a line in here or something that
completely flew over my head uh because
yeah I understand the dad wanting to
protect his son and take him away uh
panadette Brian Cranston want to take
them away uh however he knows like I
thought there could have been a little
bit more Triumph of the of the of the
panda Spirit perhaps with the trauma
that he went through with what happened
with the village before and losing his
mom and then this is a big part of what
he has to overcome acceptance of that
being a part of his life like like in
the first film like trauma was part of
him accepting himself yeah and then like
Poe could have helped teach him about
that along the way and and that's a that
could be a big part of what leaned into
his decision to lie to Poe yeah to get
him out of there and maybe that's a bit
of a cliche I I know feel like you just
would have been sometimes it's cliche
you serve story I feel like it would
help this add the because some a lot of
times when this movie started like
clicking better was when they allowed
themselves to get a little dark or get a
little dramatic yeah the second half
yeah and like the cliche I wanted was
the idea that accepting yourself is so
important right like this film all three
of them but especially this one was
about accepting all the parts of you I
really wanted there to be a bit of a
play on like if you're jaded you don't
believe in yourself like I thought the
jail oh yeah I would have played with
the word play of like the Masters being
jaded and him having to not be jaded
about who he is like if you've literally
got a punt right there and I I just felt
like the not only is he becoming a
master he's fighting jaded Masters and
he has to accept himself like there was
just a few levels of subtext I wanted
yeah still a B plus because of the
second half but the other two are A's
for me and the second borders on a plus
yeah and I thought the spirit world was
beautiful too stunning stunning spirit
world I love this but it took it to the
second half yeah yeah it is interesting
I've never seen a sequel be so like oh
no I don't to love this more oh I'm back
yeah yeah it is interesting how it
brings that love back but yeah that it
is just the first half that it is a bit
of it's not even like a slog or
something like that no we just I noticed
we both kept our body language hippie
and like is it gonna get is it gonna get
is it gonna get Kung Fu Panda if we're
just waiting for it to reach the heights
that the predecessors uh were able to
and it would have been rough patent yeah
and and eventually I I think I think the
biggest Saving Grace is the fact that
this story does feel essential to
complete the package I love them and
I'll definitely be showing my kids and
I'll definitely like revisit this on my
own I might even re-watched them in the
next two years for like Kung Fu Panda 4.
does it Fork around is it next year or
two years I assumed two years because
they just like locked it all in that's
pretty animation but they could have
been like we've been working out for 10
years I hope I mean they got the rider
strike happening too so I hope it's
written yeah I hope it's done and the
animators just took time to animate you
can't just really rewrite a bunch when
you're having doing a whole big
animation movie when you've got Seth
Rogan to people like that you can't
assume it's written all the way either
like you've got to have that be flexible
oh I wonder what they'll do it is it is
fascinating because I feel like the
story is complete that I'm like what
would you do with the fourth one writers
are so malleable if if you have a if you
think of something that's hereditary
that's why I'm thinking it's this kid I
think it's him passing on the the mantle
because the time that is also passed is
interesting um and I feel like fourths
are often like the next of the warrior
let's lead the weapon four yeah you
bring in Chris uh
hand down the franchise and then it
comes back 25 years later
we're here for your Lethal Weapon
references all day all day Lethal Weapon
five directed by Mel Gibson coming 2027.
I know I can't wait it's gonna be dark
is finally gonna die oh Riggs is
supposed to have died every time Mel's
gonna finally kill Riggs gonna be the
the uh the most violent one two 100 I
just wonder if Mel cups can get that
tone down what do we uh what are we
checking um I wanted us to see when Kung
Fu Panda okay and then uh I wanted to do
a patreon the day shout out and then
after that good time for me to pee okay
again I gotta pick what is wrong with
you all right I'll keep them I'll keep
them company
trying to drink a gallon a day I think
he had a gown before he showed up
this is sick problem yeah it's coming in
2024. that's what it says here guys
acting like an idiot What's this called
Kung Fu Panda Legends of Awesomeness nah
that's not the same thing that's a
completely different thing is it oh
there's a show
hey is this show good
oh my God what the show ref is around
for 2011 to 2016.
is this a well-regarded series
can you guys comment because I'm
realizing right now that this is a
one-way conversation because I am
recording this prior to you being able
to actually listen to what I'm saying
Kung Fu Panda Legends just killing the
time easily could have just cut this out
of the video but instead I decided to
just be here stay on camera in hopes
that Coy would get back here in time for
me to finish talking it's not coming up
on here Kung Fu Panda Legends of
Awesomeness here we go let's type this
in 73 audience score
oh and Lucy Lou did do the voice like
she came back for that
well there's a lot of episodes
there's Mike Winger do we like him as
Poe he can't replace Jack Black who's
his mic Winger's guy a mick Winger got
his name wrong
yeah he was Bill All His Highest on
Rotten Tomatoes the law and new breed of
hero
he could do better
um
what else has it done oh he voices Iron
Man and Marvel's Avengers is he doing
like a Jack Black impression
I imagine what he's doing is a Jack
Black imagine what is Kung Fu Panda the
pause of Destiny
what are these other things do people
like these other things
I don't know fascinating stuff but yeah
I kind of wanted a little bit more of
Kate Hudson as well I thought that she
was an interesting character to have
there and Brian Cranston
he does you know a lot of us do
associate himself what's great is like
he's got the two characters of um Hal
from Malcolm in the Middle and he's also
got you know um Walter White from
Breaking Bad so it's cool to see a
little bit more of that Hal side come
out of him anyway
at one point I don't know if he's gonna
get that reference comes out of 2024
let's do a patron of the day shout out
just could have done it while you were
gone I was surprised you didn't did you
just made up about a movie that's out in
a year yeah I was looking up these
things called Kung Fu Panda the pause of
Destiny and Kung Fu Panda the show that
Ranford like seven years
Legends of Awesomeness was it Jack Black
no it's some guy named Mick Wingard I
don't know what the hell he's done wow
good for him Lucy Luke came back and
said James Hong wow uh is there we
usually check Rotten Tomatoes scores
while we're here yeah fun I mean it's a
tradition yeah we could this is what the
people want I could have done it earlier
I mean could have
people are here for the long game all
right 86. that's still pretty good solid
79 audiences about how I feel I think I
think it landed at like a B plus yeah
that's like actually that's more like a
c but uh yeah no no no that's fine uh so
this is the lowest
rated one how to do box office
um I mean enough to warn a Kung Fu Panda
and how long ago was that 2016. okay
seven years yeah it's gonna be a kid
you think so I think it's gonna be like
Young Avengers everything's we've all
become parents all right let's see
let's look at Kung Fu Panda 2 first okay
two maybe
oh that's a great internet a half a
billion dollars internationally 75 of
the box office International wow yeah
that's a great International 666 total
that's bananas money
um so yeah this wait which this one
dropped off yeah this one dropped off by
a little bit Yeah a good amount actually
like a hundred and thirty thousand of
the thirty thousand years
130 million dollars it uh dropped off by
still a big International Market but uh
both both dropped domestic and
international yeah yeah but still half a
billion dollar movie weren't in the
fourth one
I mean this really didn't feel as big
either it didn't it didn't I think the
villain issue I think the fact that it
leaned younger five million dollars
cheaper to make and it shows every frame
every million dollar that feels cheap
where was it I can see it on screen I'm
also fascinated by the fox Dream Work
combo at all that's really interesting
to me like the studio element they
ruined it yep Fox came in just caught
they don't even exist anymore they do
they're at Disney patron of the day
Shadow what'd you guys think of the
movie leave your thoughts down below is
this your favorite where would you rank
it I know there's some people I know our
audience someone comes in and goes I
don't know it's my favorite It's usually
the top comment happy for him good for
them I'm not uh two one three for me uh
yeah that's my exact rating it's pretty
it's pretty obvious about halfway
through it was like two and three but
then I got better still though still two
on three yeah but that's uh it's still a
good movie that's still a great Trilogy
I put this in the top 10 trilogies it
stuck The Landing more than a lot of
thirds do right about Terminator three
right above Return of the King I mean
obviously
um hold on I'm looking for my list
guardians of my top five trilogies now
all right koi say patron of the day
shout out uh patron of the day shout out
I want to shout out the great the one
the only Everett pixel might Baker
because your name has a parenthesis with
a cool moniker in the middle of it and I
feel like that makes you exciting also
your last name Baker probably over the
years was originally had a baker in your
family and they kept that name like the
Smiths that were blacksmiths I think
it's cool when the last name is from the
before times when we just Mound people
we were like hey you do this job you're
a thatcher like in the night's tale like
William Thatcher his father was a man
who made roofs and he's the son of that
man I like when a name is strong and
mighty and about what your ancestors did
for a living do you bake I hope so we
appreciate you being a patron
well done
that's how you shout out I'm just gonna
have you record all these in advance the
makeup stuff about every neighborhood
history like here's coin doing the
Patriots I can't wait to see you all
right enjoy that bacon thank you thank
you you guys for be here we'll see you
guys soon
foreign